hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in his article the ethical significance
of cost benefit analysis for business
and the professions Robert Audi is going
to make a case why people other than
utilitarians
ought to take cost benefit analysis
seriously at least in apply to ethics
particularly in business ethics and one
of the groups who he is reaching out to
or targeting are what we call virtue
ethicists and if you're not familiar
with this idea it's often associated
with Aristotle and a number of other
thinkers the stoics would be examples of
virtue ethicists and it continues all
the way down to the present there's a
supposed Revival of virtue ethics which
is really just a Revival of virtue
ethics and anglo-american philosophy
because it never went away in other
philosophical traditions and the idea is
that in ethics it's not an enough just
to identify what the right thing or the
wrong thing is to do we want to think
about people's characters and character
traits good and bad and how these are
developed and how they affect motivation
so you know in traditional Greek ethics
on the one hand we had Aristotle who's
kind of an outlier identifying a whole
bunch of Virtues and then we had you
know the cardinal virtues tradition that
goes all the way back to somebody like
you know Plato or the the cynics uh the
epicureans also acknowledge these the
stoics do so you know wisdom Justice
courage Temperance and they might place
other traits underneath these like great
solidness right that Aristotle trade
separately but the idea is that we can
identify certain basic
habits traits whatever we want to call
them that we ought to cultivate and to
be a good person means not just doing
the right thing or doing good things or
making good decisions but doing it out
of virtue right so having those traits
developed and so we can ask ourselves
this big question all right so cost
benefit analysis doesn't really say much
about that
what roles could cost benefit analysis
have or play in virtue ethics as
traditionally understood and Audi is
going to say you know it may seem that
cost benefit analysis could have at best
a minor role and he then says you know
that's not what I want to say this
diagnosis seems kind of superficial but
why would they say that so he says
taking a decision to blow the whistle
rather than protest internally the
example he's been using we might use an
analysis of cost benefit to choose an
optimal way of proceeding but the basic
decision must be made in terms of what
he calls our attack Notions such as
veracity Fidelity and beneficence we
decide first how to be what kind of
person to be right in the situation of
choice what character traits such as
veracity should govern our conduct only
then does probability or number
crunching come in and this is what he
says is actually kind of superficial so
he's trying to make a case
for
you know why it is that it wouldn't just
be we start with these traits and then
maybe we use cohes benefit analysis
merely instrumentally and he's got a
couple points that is going to make
about this
so he says um can we not reflect on how
valuable it is to be faithful to have
that character trait and to exhibit it
in a given situation so could we assign
numerical values to some of these
different virtues and you know assigning
it perhaps to having the virtue or
acting on The Virtue or being motivated
by that displaying it in action so you
know we could ask that about how
valuable is it to be truthful that's
what veracity is honesty faithfulness
you know Fidelity loyalty following
through and commitments benevolence
doing good to other people right which
is actually for for some virtue ethics a
part of Justice right
so that's one good consideration
and then we do have another one this is
where it gets a little bit more
controversial
some virtue ethicists want to say that
virtues never conflict with each other
right and others would say well they do
conflict with each other except in
somebody who's fully developed and we're
not sure if we've ever seen somebody
like that so it may be a purely ideal
case and then there's other virtue
ethics this for a perfectly fine saying
there are going to be at certain times
irreconcilable
conflicts between particular virtues
right perhaps faithfulness and veracity
could come into conflict and the one
that Audi is going to use is
faithfulness and benevolence
and he's going to say yeah these
actually can come into conflict with
each other and he gives an example
coming from actual business ethics The
Merck Corporation had to decide whether
to expend considerable resources to
contribute to curing river blindness
and you know there's there's two things
going on here the company itself the
decision makers could be acting
virtuously in accordance with the virtue
of benevolence but
yeah that's a company so it's supposed
to be making money actually maximizing
profits for its shareholders so doing an
action that is in accordance with
motivated by one virtue could actually
conflict with what another virtue would
dictate in those circumstances and
Audi's suggesting that perhaps we could
use cost benefit analysis to figure this
out right and he's got another example
here faithfulness to a friend resulting
in allowing the performance of
inefficient work affecting a large
number of people so what we can do is
assign numbers to represent the
respective values we have to say well
how valuable is it to be X in this and
then we look at them and compare them
and decide for the option that seems to
have the highest overall value and he
says that you know
we can add a further wrinkle might there
not be questions as to whether we really
would be exhibiting a given value by
performing a given deed say because
beneficence towards one party might fail
to be beneficence towards another and
thereby fail to exhibit beneficence
overall he doesn't give an example there
but we can easily think of things like
you show beneficence to your children
but that means that you Slough off at
work and you don't do the things that
you ought to do as a customer service
representative helping other people with
their cases right because you're so
distracted by your children the
beneficence that you're showing them
you're not really beneficent in that
case so those are some good
considerations and then he's going to
consider two particular virtues
within which there seems to be more
scope for cost benefit analysis and I
leave it to you those who know something
about virtue ethics to think did he
perhaps miss an opportunity to talk
about other virtues and how they could
involve cost-benefit analysis for
example courage or Temperance or you
know virtues like those so he talks
about practical wisdom or what we can
call Prudence right it says on any
version of virtue ethics practical
wisdom plays an essential role and this
is this is quite true in any real virtue
ethics not just people coming up with
lists of Virtues practical wisdom in
traditional virtue ethics is really
Central and he says where can it come in
when a cost benefit framework is
incorporated and he says ranking ranking
the different values may require
uh practical wisdom so doing
cross-benefit analysis well in a virtue
ethics perspective needs practical
wisdom to be cultivated and he says even
greater reflection may be needed to
estimate how much more important one
value is for than another so if we're
going to Think Through the conflicts we
need practical wisdom as well and
practical wisdom in virtue ethics is not
reducible to rules or decision
procedures like that for example of
cost-benefit analysis so it's something
else that is supervening that is adding
something in but he says uh this is not
to ignore the need for practical wisdom
in calculating certain probabilities we
have to think about you know evidential
testimony the people that giveth
practical wisdom is needed for that and
so he he considers the idea that a
cost-benefit framework is compatible
with virtue ethical thinking and then he
says there's also room
to bring in quantification to the aid of
this thinking and to practical wisdom
itself so instead of
cost-benefit analysis merely being one
tool out of many for practical wisdom
there will be according to Audi some
cases in which cost benefit analysis
has to be used for applications of
wisdom doesn't mean that we need to make
a whole spreadsheet or anything like
that he says
so he gives an example consider a
decision on salary distribution in a
given year now this is also a matter of
justice as we're going to talk about in
just a moment but it is also practical
wisdom
a manager might have responsibility for
a dozen employees doing four different
kinds of jobs and relative to half a
dozen relevant variables you might think
the chief virtue here is justice
but if we seek to represent all of the
relevant variables for a cost-benefit
analysis we might also think about
another consideration the responsibility
to keep the team strong for the sake of
the overall organization that might make
replaceability of an employee relevant
in a way it might not be if only Justice
is in consideration so practical wisdom
brings other considerations in and he
says this leads us to a comprehensive
representation right and he also talks
about thinking about uh Merit this is
where we're going to get to talking
about Justice directly and he says that
so we're going to make you know some
sort of decision about who gets what
money who gets what rewards for the work
that they've done how do we decide the
Merit who is deserving of this and to
what extent and he says that there's a
lot of different things that cost
benefit analysis brings to the table
one benefit is the possibility of
rationally notice that rationally
combining different factors especially
when some are positive and some are
negative another is making sure we don't
treat one person better than another who
is equally deserving right and so he
says let's think of an example imagine
that the criteria for judging the sales
people are
sales figures generation of customer
satisfaction
contributions to the advertising plan
efficiency and paperwork time on the job
management of displays supportiveness
towards others on the team and he says
even if we can reasonably give scores to
an employee for each of these and if we
didn't need probabilities to represent
uncertainties weighing these factors for
one person as compared to the others is
very difficult
without numbers without quantification
we need to assign some numbers they may
not be perfect numbers but we need to
have some way of evaluating right and so
he says that if the goal is to realize
the virtue of fairness
these kinds of calculations done in cost
benefit analysis may be in practice
indispensable so here at least in
Justice or fairness we see that in some
applications of it particularly in
business settings cost benefit analysis
may be not just an adjunct not just a
tool but a essential
part of what it means to think through
things in a just manner the virtue of
Justice in this case in these cases
would require something like cost
benefit analysis so Audi's making a case
here and again you could think about
could this apply to other virtues that
are generally recognized by virtue
ethicists he stops here with just
prudence and Justice perhaps selecting
what he thinks are the best cases but we
could extend this particular way of
thinking about the relationship between
virtue ethics and cost benefit analysis
a little bit further and you know you
might want to think about that on your
end